ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูครูหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ทุกคนค่ะครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะวันนี้
วันนี้วันจันทร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
วันที่ 9 ก็โหที่ 10 วันที่ 9 เดือนอะไร
คะเดือน
พฤษภาคมปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
ปีคศอะไรคะมีข้อ 2022
อ่ะค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวาน
นี้วันอาทิตย์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 8 ค่ะค่ะเดือน
เดือน
พฤษภาคมปีพตที่ผช
2565 ปีคศที่ข้อ
2022 ค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะรุ่งนี้วัน
อังคารค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 10 ค่ะเดือนเดือน
พฤษภาคมปีพตตปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศมีข้อ
2022 หากค่ะตอนตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา 10:00 นค่ะ 10 โมงกี่นาทีคะ 4
นาทีค่ะ
10:40 น
ครับรางวัล
เป็นตอนกลางวันน้องฉันนี้ล่ะเลยผู้หญิง
ความไม่ค่อยได้ยินเสียงเลยไม่ค่อยได้ยิน
เสียงผู้หญิงหรอคะมีค่ะสักครู่นะคะเขาผู้
หญิงเปิดเสียงตัวเองก่อนได้ยินชัดขึ้นไหม
คะ
ไหนเห็นไหมคะฮัลโหล
ดึกเลยมันแก่
แป๊บนึงนะคะ
หน้าเดี๋ยวขอเพราะว่าครูฟ้าไม่ค่อยได้ยิน
เดี๋ยวผู้หญิงเปิดเสียงก่อนได้ยินไหมคะ
ได้ยินแล้วค่ะชัดเป้าขี่โอเคผู้หญิงลืม
เปิด Audio นะคะอะครูฟ้าได้ยินแล้วดีเลย
ค่ะครูหญิงถ้ามีคำถาม
อยากจะถามครูฟ้าค่ะ
ผู้หญิงมีคำถามอะไรคะหนูอย่างนี้คำถามว่า
ครูฟ้านะครูฟ้านะคะครูฟ้าคิดว่า
นักเรียนนักเรียนเนาะคนอเมริกาคนจีนคน
ญี่ปุ่นคนอังกฤษคนยุโรปเนี่ยนักเรียน
เนี่ยนะคะ
[เพลง]
ขอมอบอะไรประเทศไทย
นักเรียนชอบอะไรประเทศไทยหรอดูฝาคิดว่า
ฟังคิดไม่ใช่ภาษาไทยนะไม่ใช่ภาษาไทย
ว่าคิดว่า
อาหาร
วัดวัดเขาสั่งให้กูป่าวบอกหนึ่งอาหารไทย
วัด
ราคาหวัดฟ้าคิดใช่ไหมคิดค่ะคลิปงาไปคิด
ค่ะผู้หญิงคิดว่านักเรียนชอบอะไรคะผู้
หญิงคิดว่าว่านักเรียนชอบหนึ่งทะเล
ทะเลแล้วก็สองเนี่ย
คิดเหมือนครูฟ้าค่ะก็คือวัด
เพราะว่าผู้หญิงคิดว่าเวลานักเรียนมา
ประเทศไทยนักเรียนเนี่ยชอบไปดูวัด
แล้วนักเรียนก็คิด
ว่าเวลานักเรียนชอบมากๆเลยจบว่าเอาอ่ะ
ก็สวยใช่ไหมคะใจค่ะวัดสวยนะเวลาที่นัก
เรียนมา
ประเทศไทยมากรุงเทพฯวัดที่นักเรียนจะไปดู
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าณวัดแรกเนี่ยน่าจะเป็น
วัดนี้ค่ะอันนี้คือวัดอะไรคะวัดคนหาย
เรียกวัดพระแก้วพระวัดพระแก้วแห้ล
อันนี้ไม่ใช่นะเนี่ยสายตาแต่ Wat  phra
kaew วัดพระแก้วเนี่ยครูฟ้าดูสวยไหมคะ
เอาไหวคันเรียนดู
สวยมากอ่ะแต่ถ้านักเรียนจะไปจะเข้าไปใน
วัดพระแก้วเนี่ยไม่ฟรีไม่ฟรี
ไม่ฟรีหรอเอากี่บาททักผู้หญิงผู้หญิงคิด
ว่า
550 บาทนะโอ้โอ๋หาเก่ง 10 บาทเลยใช่ค่ะ
ไม่ฟรีแต่สวยใช่ไหมนี้ก็วัดในกรุงเทพนะคะ
วัดพระแก้วอยู่ในกรุงเทพฯได้ไหมนักเรียน
มากรุงเทพก็ไปดูวัดพระแก้วแล้วก็ยังมีอีก
ค่ะครูฟ้ามีวัดอะไรอีกนะคะผู้หญิงคุณฟ้า
รู้ไหมวัดอะไร
วัดโคเหรอใช่ค่ะวัดโพธิ์
ทำไมครูฟ้ารู้วัดโพธิ์ก็เห็นยักษ์น่ะสวย
นี้ใช่ไหมเป็นสีหน่อยนะคะครูฟ้าเห็นยัตอา
ดท่านผู้ฟังเพลงกิจัวัดโพธิ์
ชายๆค่ะครูฟ้าเก่งมากวัดโพธิ์สวยไหมคะ
สวยค่ะครูผู้หญิง
สาธุเวลานัดนักเรียนอาจจะคิดวัดโทวัด
โพธิ์อะไรนี่ไงถ้านักเรียนมาวัดโพธิ์นัก
เรียนก็จะไปดูอะไรคะครูฟ้า
พระนอน
พระรูปนี้นอนหนูครุไปตีมากๆนี่มากเลยหรอ
ว่ากูบ้าแล้วยาวกินยาเอามากๆ
กูฟ้าไปดูหรือยัง
อ้ำไปแล้วเอามะเคยไปแลนด์เคยไปแล้วใช่ไหม
คะผู้หญิงก็เคยไปแล้วใช่มั้ยใหญ่แต่คิด
ว่าวัดโพธิ์ท่านักก็จะดูพระนอนก็ไม่ฟรีนะ
จ่ายเงินน้นเหมือนกันเพราะถ้ายอด
เมื่อก่อนนะคิดว่า
150 หรือ 200 ไม่แน่ใจนะ
150 หรือ 200 บาทอันนี้ไม่แน่ใจนะคะ
เพราะคนไทยไม่จ่ายเงินคนไทยฟรีนะครูผู้
หญิงกับครูฟ้าก็เลยแบบไม่รู้
นี่ก็วัดโพธิ์แล้วก็มากรุงเทพเนี่ยไปดู
อ่ะวัดพระแก้ว
วัดโพธิ์แล้วก็ต้องไปอีกหนึ่งวัดค่ะครู
ฟ้าไปวัดอะไรอีกคะผู้หญิงนี่ค่ะวัดอรุณโอ
โอ๊โอวัดอรุณผู้ชายอันนี้เนี่ยวัดพระแก้ว
วัดโพธิ์ทำไมนักเรียนจะไปวัดอรุณเนี่ย
ต้องข้ามแม่น้ำนะคะอันนี้คือแม่น้ำ
เจ้าพระยานักเรียนไหนก็ต้องนั่งเรือ
ค่ะเหรียญแล้วก็ต้องๆที่นี่นะคะไปที่ท่า
เรือณท่าเรือนี้แล้วก็ไปที่วัดอรุณ
หมูสวยไหมคะครูฟ้า
สวยมากค่ะคู่หญิงสาวๆสีขาวเวลาดูสีขาว
เนาะอันนี้เรียกอะไรนะคะครูฟ้าอาเจดีย์
สายเจดีย์สีขาวใช่ไหมเจดีย์ณวัดอรุณณวัด
อรุณเนี่ยถ้านักเรียนอยากจะไปที่เจดีย์ก็
ไม่ฟรีไม่มีโป้
ฟรีกี่บาทนักผู้หญิงว่า 150 บาทนะ
คนไทยก็ไม่ฟรี
ฟรีคนไทยเนี่ยสิบบาทที่เจดีย์นะถ้าอยากจะ
ไปที่เจดีย์แล้วก็ขึ้นขึ้นเจดีย์เนี่ยไม่
ฟรีนะคะเห็นไหมเนี้ย
กรุงเทพฯใช่ไหมคะมีวัดที่นักเรียนเนี่ย
รู้จักกันจะมีวัดอรุณหรอแล้วก็วัดอะไรคะ
ครูฟ้า
วัดโพธิ์ค่ะแล้ววะอะไรคะวัดพระแก้วค่ะ
ต่ายค่ะวัดพระแก้วน้องอ่ะนี่นักเรียน
เนี่ยรู้จักวัดที่กรุงเทพฯแล้วครูผู้หญิง
ก็มีคำถาม
ผู้หญิงจะถามข้อใดคือฟ้าคะ
เห้อนักเรียนมา
กรุงเทพฯไปดูวัดไปวัดนั้นเรียน
ผู้ชายผู้หญิงสมัยเราก็ไปวัด
ไปที่วัดเนี่ยนะเรียนจะเห็นอะไรบ้างที่
วัด
[เพลง]
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าที่วัดเนี่ยมีอะไรบ้าง
ให้ครูฟ้าตอบหรือ
ให้กรูฟ้า
วาดรูปวาดรูปค่ะ
วิ่งก็จะขีดเส้นให้กูฟ้าของอื่นไม่แน่ใจ
ว่า
มึงอ่ะประมาณนี้แล้วกันนะครูฟ้า
ฝากเวลาเราเบอร์โทรไปวัดเนี่ยเราเห็นอะไร
บ้างที่วัดค่ะให้ครูฟ้าวาดก่อน
[เพลง]
ได้ค่ะผู้หญิง
นักเรียนคิดว่าครูฟ้าจะว่าอะไร
นกแล้วนะภูฟ้า
อันนี้นกเหรอ
เอาสีเหลืองเฮ้ย
ครูฟ้าอาเอาครูหญิงคิดว่าครูหญิงรู้แล้ว
นะคะว่าครูฟ้าวาดอะไร
ใช้งาน Buri หญิงผู้หญิงรู้ได้ใช่ไหมรู้
แล้วค่ะพระใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะก็หญิงพระค่ะ
พระเอกมีข้าวใช่มั้ยเวลานักเรียนไปวัดนัก
เรียนก็ต้องเห็นพระนะคะร.ร.อะแต่ๆนะแต่
ถ้านักเรียนไปวัดพระแก้ววันพระแก้วเนี่ย
ไม่มีพระนะคะไม่มีมีพระหาไม่มีไม่มีนะอ่า
แต่วัดเนี่ยมีพระใช่ไหมคะใช้อ่ะครูหญิง
บ้างผู้หญิงเห็นอะไรคะเวลาไปวัด
ไม่มีคิวค่ะขอโทษ
คุณฟ้ารู้ไหม
คะรู้นะถ้า
อะไรคะครูฟ้าพ.ร.บ
ถ้าทารูป
ใส่ค่ะพระครูฟ้าเนี่ยพระครูฟ้าเนี่ยเป็น
คน
หายใจเลยหายใจอ่ะแต่ของครูหญิงเนี่ยพระ
พุทธรูปเนี่ยไม่ใช่คนนะไม่กินไม่นอนค่ะ
เป็นปูนซีเมนต์อ่ะพระพระพุทธรูปค่ะครูฟ้า
ที่วัดมีอะไรอีกคะ
ได้ค่ะได้ค่ะรอสักครูกะ
อ้าวแต่ว่าเล็กๆได้ไหมหนา
หนี
นี้หลังชาหรอ
เอาก็หิว
ใยออกนั่งฆ่า
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าผู้หญิงรู้นะเดา
รอรอรอรอปรูฟ้าว่าเสร็จแต่ครูหญิงคิดว่า
ว่ารู้แล้วว่าครูฟ้าวาดอะไร
ผู้หญิงจะรู้แล้วหรอผู้หญิงเก่งค่ะครูฟ้า
อีกหรือยังคะ
มีบันไดด้วยเหรอคะมี 5 ผู้หญิงนะรู้ไหม
หน้าคืออะไรผู้หญิงท้องแล้วก็ยังคิดอีก
อย่างนึง
จัดครูหญิงคิดว่ากูอยู่รู้และจริงๆว่าคือ
อะไรอะไรอ่ะผู้หญิง
กุฏิพระช่วยไหมๆหาบ้านพระนั่นแหละตายบ้าน
ของพระน้องพระที่ครูฟ้าวาดสมัยพระต้องนอน
นอนที่บ้านของพระนะคะบ้านพระเนี่ยคนไทย
เรียกกรุติระเบิดถ้าอยากกินหน่อยนะแต่
เป็นบ้านของพระๆอ้ะฟ้าวัดบ้านของพระที่
เป็นคนนะคะผู้หญิงว่าบ้านของพระ
ไหนผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงบอกกูฟ้าทำไมอ่ะ
ก็รู้เลย
นั่งสิ
ฟ้ารู้ไหมครูหญิงว่าอะไร
ผู้หญิงวาดโบสถ์
ใส่ค่ะแต่มันไม่ค่อยสวยนะคะนักเรียน
ผู้หญิงวาดโบสถ์ค่ะพระพุทธรูปเนี่ยอยู่
ข้างในโบสถ์อ่ะใจครูฟ้าที่วัดมีอะไรอีกคะ
คุณของอะไรสกุลฟ้าเขียน
โป้นักเรียนไปวัดนักเรียนจะเห็นอะไรอีก
หมาอ่า
ผู้หญิงหรือผู้หญิงรู้ตั้งแต่เห็นหูแล้ว
ก็ครูมา
สิ่งนะที่วัดในประเทศไทยราคาที่แบบเนี้ย
ไม่ใช่วัดพระแก้ววัดโพธิ์วัดอรุณที่เรา
ให้ดูนะวัดที่คนไทยไปมีหมาเยอะมากๆใช่นัก
เรียนบ่าเยอะมากค่ะหมานสาธุค่ะเฮง
หมาหมา
ที่วัดยังไม่จับนะคะนักเรียนมันกัดนะ
เขี้ยว
อ่ะครูฟ้าภูผาว่าเสร็จแล้วทำไมผู้หญิงเขา
Copy ของครูฟ้านะ
อะไหล่ค่ะผู้หญิงถ้าชอบอันนี้คือสิ่งแรก
ที่ตอนแรกผู้หญิงคิดว่ากูฟ้าว่าหน้านี้ไง
นั่นก็คือ
บ้านหมา
เตะ
ไม่ใช่บ้านหมากไม่ใช่ค่ะ
แล้วเราก็จะมีพระพุทธรูปใช่ไหมอันนี้ก็มี
พระพุทธรูปเหมือนกันนะคะ
อะไรคะครูป๊ารู้ไหม
ไม่หัก
ศาลาและมีพระพุทธรูปด้วยเหรอนี่บางวัดมี
วัดที่บ้านผู้หญิงวัดใกล้ๆบ้านผู้หญิงมี
อ้าวหรอๆศาลาเวลาหูฟ้าทำอาหารทำอาหารแล้ว
ก็อยู่ที่วัดก็จะมีพระชัยพระพระครูฟ้า
เนี่ย
ที่นี่แล้วก็น่ามอร์ตาร์ 3 ภาษาว่าตนแล้ว
ก็มีคนคนๆที่นี่นะศาลาค่ะ
สายให้ครูฟ้าคนอีกคนละ 1 อย่างที่วัดมี
อะไร
ที่วัดก็ต้องมี
ครูฟ้าจะวาดอะไรฮะจบแล้วเหรอคะ
ครูฟัง
God
ก็คือฟ้า
อาร์
เจดีหรอใช่หาเจดีย์
เจดีย์เจดีย์ใช่ค่ะณวัดต้องมีเจดีย์อะครู
หญิงว่าร่าง
ว่าทำไมผู้หญิงผู้หญิงเริ่มต้นเหมือนกัน
หมดเลย
มีบันไดนะคะผู้หญิงกำลังวาดบันได
จะเขาผู้หญิงขยับลงมาหน่อยนึงนะคะ
ตรงนี้แล้วกัน
รู้ป๊ารู้ไหมครูหญิงว่าอะไรอ่ะอ่า
เขาเรียกอะไรนะ
เบนเม้นท์ฟ้ารู้ใช่ไหมเวลามีคน
ขับขอโทษค่ะมองไม่เห็นมีที่นี้ใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วก็คนนี้เนี่ยตายโอ๊ยตายแล้วก็ไว้ที่
เมรุแล้วก็เผานะคะเขาเนาะมีเมย์นะคะที่
วัด
แต่จริงๆเนี่ยถ้านักเรียนไปวัดน้องก็จะ
เป็นสิ่งที่นักเรียนเห็นนะแต่เราไม่อาจจะ
เห็นอีกอย่างอีกอิอิที่เราสองคนไม่ได้วาด
นะคะก็คือจะมี
ดอกบัวใช่มั้ยดอกบัว
มี
เทียนหรอแล้วก็
มีทูตนะคะอ่าที่วัดเนี่ยก็จะมีน็อตถ้านัก
เรียนไปวัดนะคะก็จะเป็นสิ่งที่นักเรียน
เห็นเนาะมีอะไรบ้างคะครูฟ้ามีพระค่ะอัน
นี้นะพระนะคะแล้วก็ 2
ก็ได้ค่ะ
3r อะบ้านมีพระบ้านสัตว์กุฏิพระกะกุจิม 4
เจดีย์
อ่าพระพุทธรูปค่ะ 6
[เพลง]
อะไรนะโบสถ์โบสถ์อร์โบน 7
ศาลา
เมนแต่ก็ 9
เค้าเรียกว่าดอกบัว
เทียน
ทู 3 หรือว่าดอกไม้ธูปเทียนก็ได้นะคะอัน
นี้ก็จะเป็นสิ่งที่นักเรียนเห็นที่วัดนะ
คะล้วนนักเรียนมีอะไรอีกไปเรียนชอบวัด
ประเทศไทยไหมก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้ส่วน
วีดีโอนี้ครีมกับคะแล้วก็ต้องไปก่อนนะคะ
แล้วเจอกันวีดีโอหน้าสวัสดีค่าา